president Trump meets with top Democrats
this morning for the first time in
months
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi Pelosi and
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
want to discuss a quote big and bold
infrastructure bill the talks could show
whether any legislative compromise is
possible before the 2020 election Paula
Reid is at the White House so Paula does
it seem like they might be able to work
together on anything this group John
it's not looking good in a letter
yesterday to the president Democratic
leaders Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
said they're looking forward to hearing
the president's ideas on how to fund
infrastructure but economic advisor
Larry Kudlow said yesterday the White
House is not committed to any specific
funding method and several top
administration officials tell CBS News
the White House is not bringing any
ideas to the table today now the
president's previous meetings with
Pelosi and Schumer have devolved into
finger-pointing bickering and even the
president walking out in frustration the
White House says the conversation today
will likely extend other highly-charged
issues including immigration and border
security John well that's right Paula
the last time they were together they
had one of those finger-pointing
sessions on the issue of immigration the
president's now issued new restrictions
on asylum seekers so what can you tell
us about those restrictions and on this
issue of immigration if there's any
possible agreement last night the
president issued a memorandum having to
do specifically with asylum seekers he
wants to make it harder for them to get
work while their cases are being
processed
he's also adding a filing fee for asylum
applications now he also wants to impose
a 180 day time limit to resolve these
claims as immigration courts are
currently backlogged with hundreds of
thousands of cases and this push comes
as the president seeks to rally his base
ahead of 2020 but it's unclear whether
any of these initiatives will hold up in
court
all right Paula thanks so much Paula
Reid at the White House the president
Trump organization and his three oldest
children are now suing Deutsche Bank and
Capital One to stop them from releasing
his banking records to Congress to House
committees have put out subpoenas for
those documents the president's lawyers
claim the request from Congress has no
legitimate or lawful purpose House
Democrats say this lawsuit is meritless
the subpoenas are part of an
investigation of the president's
finances Georgia Bank has already said
it will hand over appropriate
information to all authorized
investigations